hello everyone sorry about no video
yesterday I really thought I would have
the time to make one but my train got
delayed and I was I was home late for
about more than an hour and I came home
really late and really didn't feel like
doing a video which it would just be
pointless as I was like completely
sleeping when I got home but that's not
something that's uncommon for creation
railways I just thought maybe this time
everything will go smoothly but okay
that being said we did win second place
as a team so so that was that was nice
yes pletely got first place so
congratulations to them as well but it's
time to return to the 2013 candidates
tournament we have a game from round
five it's vastly bunch of vs. Magnus
Carlsen and of course before we check
out the game we do have we do have a
couple of photos from from this match up
here we have a nice photo of a van choke
it seems like he's staring at the camera
but probably not he's just contemplating
and predicting a great victory over a
highest rated player in the world Magnus
Carlsen here was eventually just figure
out what he's gonna play against Magnus
Carlsen and it will be d4 because he's
thinking okay Carson is the highest
rated player in the world but it's me
who won the 1991 Linares tournament half
a point ahead of Gary Kasparov if you
haven't checked out the dead series I
also made a series about eventually
winning the 1991 Allen RS tournament so
I will put a link to that in the
description below if by any chance you
want to check that out and here we have
a photo of blurry eventually and there
is a sharp caution in the background so
that being said let's see this game like
I said if I shook has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 Knight to f6
we have c4 g6 Knight to c3 and d5 so
there's a roomful defense on the board
and it's very interesting here you have
there's even a photo of the moment
there's a d5 on the board and now event
is really really thinking hard how to
proceed here against the green felt its
he probably didn't expect the groom fold
against divine chop but it's very
exciting because in round five get
I was playing against Peter Svidler
sweedler had the white pieces and again
and also chose the groom for defense
against him and the groom for defense is
was a swingers favorite open a defense
with black so it was a very interesting
because there was a d5 on two boards and
evangelist Coulson and on sweedler
versus gay fund and you know people were
joking around that as none of them were
making any moves that even she was
waiting to see what a sweet letter will
play against the groom field as he was
known to be a groom for specialist and
that Villa was waiting to see what event
you would play against the groom foe but
the games were very different and I will
show you Laura's game as well from this
round so I'm sure you'll enjoy it so if
I took after something in goes Bishop to
f4 so the so called Brinkman attack
Bishop to g7 and the Knight to f3 now we
have the Hungarian attack on the board
castles and III c 5d captures on c5 and
Queen to a5 rook to see one by one choke
rook to d8 and here Queen to a for Queen
to a4 aventure kind of offers a trade of
Queens but also gives up the c5 pawn
it's not you can't really hold your
extra pawn by playing something like C
captures and v5 Knight captures on d5
and now there's a triple attack on your
c3 Knight you have to defend at Queen b3
and now after Bishop to e6 there really
aren't that that's many good moves for
white you'd have to you'd have to defend
the brush up to c4 and now comes knife
to a6 and there's really no way to
defend defend the c5 for now and the
black got so much activity just because
White's try to hold on to the extra pawn
after something like castles captures on
c5 Queen moves captures captures and
after one more exchange Bishop will
capture on a2 and it's actually black
who is up upon so this is only one
variation but it's a it's not possible
to hold your extra pawn you can only
mess up your position so if I drew goes
Queen to a4 and cross and plays Queen
captures on c5 we have before attacking
Carlson's Queen Queen to c6 offering a
trade of
and now eventually declines Quinn to a
3d captures on c5 and now event took
place the strongest move and really
shows how Carson didn't really develop
develop his pieces accordingly he plays
beef I he plays b5 this kicks the Queen
away and the Queen can no longer defend
the c4 pawn so Bishop will be able to
capture on c4 and another thing it does
after Queen to b6 which was played in
the game now
this Knight can't really develop to a6
or to c6 he can develop the to d7 but
there he will be blocking a lot of
Carlson's other pieces from developing
so Bishop captures on c4 across and
plays Bishop to e6 we have Bishop
captures Queen captures and here we have
castles by von Schuch and now Carson has
to make a decision as this b5 pawn is
guarding a6 and also see oh sorry
also c6 he has to develop his pieces
somehow Evangelista threatening Knight
to g5 but also Knight to d4 and after
the queen is attacked he will have to
move the Queen and then Queen captures
on e7 will be will be a real problem if
he waits for event to play such a knight
move and then move the Queen for example
to d7 to still guard the point then this
night will not be able to develop
anywhere so facing such opening
difficulties crossed and decided to
sacrifice a pawn here
moves like h6 don't work because then
you again have nice the d4 attacking the
Queen but the engine really likes Bishop
to f8 so simply if the queen is attacked
the Queen can move because now these 7
point is defended but it's not not a
move a human will make you don't want
your Bishop on f8 I mean this Bishop
belongs in g7 so although the engine
likes that I don't think any human would
play this but ok after castles cousin
plays Knight B to d7 immediately
develops the night and gives up a pawn
so eventually accepts the sacrifice
Knight to g5 attacking the Queen we have
Queen to f5 and now Queen captures on e7
grabbing a clean pawn Knight to h5 as
event was threatening Queen captures on
f7
so we have night 2 H 5 attacking cross
and event troops Bishop and also now the
Queen is defending f7 rook F 2d 1x1
choke now there are also all sorts of
threats here like Bishop to c7 kicking
away this rook so the knight can be
captured so you do have to react to this
across some place knife captures on f4
we have pawn captures and i-4 and now
Bishop to f8 keeping the Queen away from
e7 Queen to e4 eventually offers the
trade of Queens Queen captures and
Knight captures and night to be 6 so
this is basically the position calls and
saw when he decided to sacrifice a pawn
he is now down upon but it's a double F
pawn and cousin said that it would be
better to play at this endgame upon down
and he really thought that he could hold
this against even shook then to then to
allow being undeveloped and then tried
to defend a d7 pawn so we have g3 rook
captures and e1 rook captures and e1 and
Bishop to e7 now attacking the g5 knight
Knight f3 rough to see 8th and 9th to e5
and here Carlsen plays rook to c7 which
is a very interesting decision as rook
to c2 does seem appealing you know you
want to grab the a pond and go after the
beep on but it actually doesn't work
because white can simply push a 4 here
and now if you capture an a4 then rock
to d7 will be very strong for white at
the bishop is under attack if you move
the bishop then you lose the f7 pawn
also be 7 point is under attack
and after you play something like King
f8 to defend the bishop then rook
captures and this will be excellent for
white like it didn't really achieve
anything and even if after a 4 if you
don't grab it if you play something like
rook to a - deciding to grab it next
again you have Knight to c3
attacking the rook rook a3 and now
Knight to e5 captures captures and you
still can't capture the pawn if you
capture the pawn again you get rook to
the 7 and you have to react to this King
f7 rook captures and black didn't really
achieve anything it's it's still an
extra pawn and a White's position is a
definitely great
so after Knight to e5 our rook to c7
cousin
simply decides that he will guard the
seventh rank kingi - we have f6 kicking
away thus this powerful knight on e5
Knight to f3 and King to f7 we have h4
rook to c2 and we have a four now again
offering a pawn but if course and
captures then rook to d7 is coming rock
to a two attacking the pawn and Knight
to c3 rook to a3 as similar as we've
seen in the previous duration and now
rook to see one here even took played
rook to c1 and he actually offered the
raw because he was once again in in
great time trouble but here Carson
actually declined the draw so even
though he's down upon he wants to play
this for the win Knight captures on a4
was played and here if you captured the
night after night captures rook captures
then it really is a drawn game the
material is is back to even but here you
want to play Knight to e4 and here it's
it's not so not so not so much a draw as
as if it as if the knight captured on a4
so rock to d3 we have rocked a c7 this
was the idea of 94 now the rook can
infiltrate on the seventh rank King e6
I'm pinning and bringing the King into
the game and now rook captures on b7
looked at e7 offering a trade and now
rook to b8 rook to d8 looked the b7 Rock
to d7 rook captures 77 now capturing the
rook not going for another repetition of
moves King capture son d7 and now Knight
to d4 so if I should be still up upon
and it's two knights against a knight
and the bishop it's hard to say if with
perfect play would it be winning or is
still a troy it's hard to say so we have
f5 Knight to g5 and the bishop captures
pawn captures so the position gets
simplified even further you want to is
still up a pawn and he still he is still
trying to win this now Knight to c3
we have h5 g captures on h5 and King to
h3 so giving up upon temporarily so the
King can now pick up all of the points
on the H file King D 6 we have king to
h4 king d5 Knight captures an f5 Knight
the b5 capturing up
now Carlson also has a pest a pond we
have King to h5 capturing upon and here
we have King to e4 King g4 and this is a
one of the more critical moments in the
game this is a move 45 and here
eventually was completely in time
trouble he was like he had to make moves
or he would run out of time
and he actually almost grabbed his King
so he picked up his King and he almost
played something like King to g4 to
defend the night and if he did this then
he would he would lose the game because
now a five wins the game there's really
no good way to stop the phone now
Knights to e3 simply a four and after
the knight blocks it now you attack the
knight Knight moves you simply keep
attacking the knight and after night 2
c1
now you have king c2 and when the night
goes back now you have a nice c3 and now
you either exchange Knights and then the
a pawn wins or here comes check and
after King to b3 now you have to move
the knight Knight 2 D 3 a 3 and F 4 now
you white will try to break through as
well and okay I know this is only a line
that could have happened if you want to
really did play the King but it's also a
very nice puzzle for you to solve how
does black win this so feel free to
pause the video and you know don't don't
be hasty so for those who founded
congratulations you are an excellent end
game player and for those who just want
to enjoy the show I hope you did not
play a 2 because if you played a 2 then
night c1 checks the King and you lose
the a to pawn and then there are too
many points on the King side white is
actually not winning this after you move
the King simply Knight captures and you
can stop all the points the move you had
found of course find of course was a
Knight to e2
now the knight from me to is guarding c1
so you can't really play Knight to c1
check and after white plays something
let's say he attacks the night there's
really no no better move here simply a
to King characters and now you have a
queen and you're winning the game so I
do hope most of you have found this but
eventually after the skin before event
you did not click in before event
replayed night to e3
and after nine three three now a five
doesn't work
now now the night we'll be able to stop
the pawn here we have nice 2d6 King 2h
692 f7 this is with check capturing on
h7 Knight captures on g5 King g6 now
Knight to h3 attacking the f2 pawn
Knight the d1 defending the pawn and
King to f3 and now it's really a dead
draw King to f5 Knight captures on f2
Knight captures on f2 and now of course
you don't want to you don't want to
capture the Knights that fool lose the
game you have to capture the pawn so
King capture Sanji three nights the d1
and of course now it's everyone can see
it's a draw but they decided to play to
play it on so here we have it a 393
calls and pushes a two you want to
capture Sun a two and in this position
it was a draw what didn't you didn't
have to even agree to a draw I mean as
this is a drone position and neither
side can win so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and a really
interesting game because this is this is
the first game where cousin got into
some serious trouble and the word event
really got got some winning chances but
Crossan decided to sacrifice a pawn and
he he made the right call you know
activity above all and he managed to
hold this position against lastly Manchu
so before I forget
yeah here we do have one photo this is
even took from the press conference
after this game but that's actually not
what I wanted to show you what I want to
show you where the standings after after
this round because we haven't had the
standings in a while so let's just check
it out let me just fix that yeah okay
here we have it so these are the
standings after round 5 so it's crossing
in first place with three and a half
points our onion also in first place
with three and a half so it's a tie
bitter sweet ler with three then kramnik
with two and a half or a jobber with two
and a half and then English cook with -
Boris Gelfand one and a half and vastly
one choke after round five in last place
with one and a half point which you know
you can see
how how chests can sometimes be unfair I
one and a half point only for Vasily one
choke and so far he is the only one to
give cos and a run for his money but you
know such such is the way of chess Maria
that's one game we will also check out
the game
wheeler versus gaff and as that's also a
very interesting game in the grünfeld
offense and yeah
I would like to thank Valentina Pia Adam
Korolev Don Dugan David sturgeon and
Rachel Simmons for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
with another game from round five of the
2013 candidates tournament thank you all
and I will see you soon